[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 11 mars
les variants plus dangereux et plus
contagieux il représente plus de deux
tiers des contaminations en france prise
de parole tout à l'heure d'olivier
veyrat qui n'a pas caché son inquiétude
notamment concernant l'île de france
des dizaines voire des centaines de
patients pourraient être transférés côté
vaccins pas de suspension d'astrazeneca
comme c'est le cas au danemark en
norvège et en islande
johnson and johnson validé par l'europe
c'est le quatrième c'est romain les
brevets sur les vaccins anti kobe
doivent-ils être levé dans le but
d'augmenter la production mondiale elle
a partagé oui clairement pour un comité
scientifique de collectif scientifique
de médecins et de syndicalistes qui
lance aujourd'hui l'appel de paris en ce
sens
des négociations sont en cours alors est
ce à la demande de l'inde et l'afrique
du sud
en mai dernier déjà l'union européenne
appelé à faire des vaccins un bien
public mondial une ambition loi partagé
par emmanuel macron mais loin de faire
l'unanimité
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire toujours l europe à
la traîne l'espagne maintient les
limitations entre régions afin de
freiner la circulation du virus avec un
objectif sauver l'été et se positionner
en tant que destination sûre du côté de
l'italie c'est l'inquiétude là aussi les
variants anglais brésiliens circule de
plus en plus le pays pourrait être
confiné partiellement aux etats unis le
plan de relance devrait être promulguée
ce jeudi par joe biden un plan de 1900
milliards de dollars voulu par le
président américain est adoptée hier par
le congrès un montant perçu comme une
montagne de dettes pour les républiques
arrière-plan qui ne répond pas à la
pandémie
le fonds monétaire international évoque
lui des retombées positives pour
l'économie mondiale
[Musique]
on débute avec donc la situation
sanitaire et des centaines de patients
en france il est un teint ducobu 19 qui
pourraient être transférés vers d'autres
régions déclarations d'olivier verrons
ce soir lors de son traditionnel point
presse du jeudi
ces transferts pourrait avoir lieu dès
la fin de cette semaine selon le
ministre de la santé la situation est
particulièrement tendue dans les
hôpitaux de cette région
le seuil des 4000 malades ducobu de 19
ans en réanimation a été à nouveau
dépassé toutes les 12 minutes
un malade du coc vide est admis en
réanimation en ile de france olivier
ferrand prévient que si l'épidémie se
poursuit à ce rythme alors nous
prendrions toutes les mesures
nécessaires et d'ores et déjà nous
préparons des transferts importants de
patients vers les autres régions qui
pourrait avoir lieu dès cette fin de
semaine
quand je dis important c'est qu'on parle
là de dizaines voire voire de centaines
de patients qui pourraient être évacués
de l'île de france vers d'autres
hôpitaux d'autres régions du territoire
national cette solidarité entre les
régions
elle est cruciale parce qu'elle permet
de sauver des vies en un an près de
mille patients ont déjà été transférés
pour cause de colis d'une région à une
autre
et notamment d'ailleurs de certaines
régions vers l'île de france au cours de
la première et de la deuxième vague et
olivier ferrand affirme ce soir qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de suspendre la
vaccination avec astrazeneca en france
plusieurs pays européens ont pourtant
décidé de suspendre son utilisation
après l'apparition de caillots sanguins
chez des personnes ayant reçu ce sérum
anglo suédois selon l agence européenne
des médicaments il y a eu 34 de
thromboembolie parmi les 5 millions de
personnes vaccinées jusqu'à présent en
europe
une enquête est en cours les détails
avec scarlett ce bain des effets
indésirables à l'effet domino en
l'espace de quelques jours
sept pays européens ont retiré du marché
des doses du vaccin astrazeneca lundi
l'autriche annoncé cesser d'administrer
un l'eau du sérum britannique après le
décès d'une infirmière
la quadragénaire est morte à la suite de
graves troubles de coagulation apparue
peu après l'injection
l'estonie la lituanie la lettonie et le
luxembourg l'ont suivi dans cette
décision et l'italie vient de faire de
même en interdisant le lot en question
ce jeudi le danemark et l'islande puis
la norvège sont allés encore plus loin
en suspendant complètement l'utilisation
du vaccin britannique décision prise
après avoir aussi constaté la formation
de caillots sanguins chez des personnes
vaccinées la population danoise salue ce
choix en fin de compte c'est
probablement la bonne chose à faire
s'ils soupçonnent que quelqu'un tombe
malade ou même en meurent alors c'est
probablement la décision la plus sûre je
me sens parfaitement en sécurité je
pense qu'ils ont fait ce qu'il fallait
lorsqu'ils ont découvert que le vaccin
n'allait pas bien
ils doivent le rendre public pour que
nous puissions tous nous en occuper et
nous sentir plus en sécurité
des réactions en chaîne qui pousse les
autorités du royaume uni à prendre la
parole publiquement
en ce qui concerne astrazeneca je suis
conscient de la situation ici nous avons
effectué tous les textes réglementaires
au royaume uni nous sommes très
confiants quant à l'innocuité du vaccin
mais nous savons aussi nous l'avons
constaté tout au long des essais qu'il
faut suivre le processus dans chaque
pays en matière de sécurité et nous
respectons évidemment l'approchent
norvégienne l'agencé européenne du
médicament se veut elle aussi rassurante
les informations disponibles à ce jour
indiquent que le nombre de
thromboembolie chez les personnes
vaccinées n'est pas supérieur à celui
observé sur l'ensemble de la population
un constat partagé ce sa part la france
sur 5 millions d'européens
trente personnes ont présenté des
troubles de la cog hill de la
coagulation le ce qu'on appelle le
rapport bénéfice / risque c'est-à-dire
le bénéfice apporté par la vaccination
est donc jugé supérieur au risque à ce
stade
à son arrivée sur le marché le vaccin
astrazeneca s'est présenté à tous les
pays européens comme un moyen
d'accélérer les campagnes de vaccination
en réunissant de qualité peu coûteux et
pouvant se conserver facilement à la
différence des vaccins modern art
et faïza des caractéristiques qui ont
parfois fait oublier l'un de ses défauts
une efficacité évalué à seulement 70 %
contre plus de 90% pour ses concurrents
des limites auxquelles viennent
s'ajouter plusieurs critiques sur les
délais de livraison émises notamment par
la présidente de la commission
européenne en personne face à l'arrivée
du vaccin johnson and johnson validé ce
jeudi par bruxelles les 27 pourraient
d'autant plus est tenté de revoir leurs
contrats avec la firme britannique
la levée des brevets sur les vaccins ont
kiko vite fait des bars en france depuis
le début de la campagne de vaccination
des associations et partis politiques
appellent à lever les brevets sur les
vaccins anti qu'ovide afin de répondre à
l'urgence de la crise sanitaire
une conférence de presse de l'appel de
paris s'est tenue ce matin en même temps
que le pcf mais une action devant l'
agence régionale de santé de l'île et
participants dénonce un système
économique
la vraie question c'est de changer le
paradigme et de et de fixer les règles
autrement et donc effectivement de lever
les brevets et permettre à ce qu'on ait
des outils de production qui les
fabrique au sud ya effectivement un
certain nombre de fabricants et on
l'avait vu une vingtaine d'années sur
les antirétroviraux qui qui sont
disponible et disposé à le faire alors
on a une autre difficulté c'est que le
gros de l'outil de production est entre
les mains principalement des big pharmas
et donc inévitablement ça suppose un
certain nombre de prises de décisions
législatives juridique en fait de règles
du jeu pour savoir qui fabrique quand
comment et pour qui surtout alors
question faut-il faire des vaccins bien
public mondial même si cette intention
est louable est elle réaliste
la france doit-elle mener cette bataille
au niveau mondial c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
eric un bouquet sénateurs pcf du nord
philippe herlin économise bonsoir à tous
les deux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on l'a dit un
collectif de scientifiques médecins
économistes syndicalistes et
responsables des ong exigent donc cette
levée un des brevets sur les vaccins
dans le but d'accroître de toute urgence
la production mondiale des négociations
sont d'ailleurs en cours
l oms à la demande de l'inde et
l'afrique du sud mais est-ce réaliste
cette demande philippe herlin pas du
tout ça c'est typiquement communiste
étatiste parce que une fois une fois
qu'on a récupéré une fois que le préfet
faisant l'hypothèse une fois qu'on a
récupéré et ce n'est pas qu'on a mis ses
brevets dans le domaine public
on fait quoi on construit des usines
pour faire des vaccins mais ça va pas ça
prend trop de temps donc il faut
réquisitionner les entreprises
donc on donc on va on va et attiser les
entreprises et puis ensuite on va la
faire marcher au bâton pour qu'elle
produise dès lors qu'elles produisent
des vaccins mais ça c'est un modèle qui
est complètement une économie dirigiste
communiste et l'histoire a montré que ça
marchait pas du tout ce mode de
fonctionnement
donc c'est une est profondément stupide
il faut au contraire jouer sur la
concurrence le fait qu'ils aient
plusieurs entreprises qui est fait
plusieurs vaccins c'est une bonne chose
et c était en concurrence et plusieurs
en sortie des vaccins maintenant on a
chacun peut les choisir
chaque pays et même chaque chaque
personne peut choisir tel vaccin plutôt
que telle autre
et donc on est dans la quête de liberté
et de concurrence qui est nettement plus
efficace pour la recherche pour la
concurrence par les prix parce que si
s'il ya un vaccin qui était dix fois
plus cher que les autres et ben ils leur
vendra aucun donc le fait qu'ils aient
plusieurs vaccins ça tire les prix vers
le bas c'est une très bonne chose et du
monde en profite
et voilà on est dans un système qui
fonctionne bien qui est efficient et
mettre ça dans le même public maintenant
ce serait se serait l'idée la plus
stupide d'affaires bonbons dans la
situation actuelle
alors éric bocquet je sens qu'il veut et
il a fait un petit bond à une idée
communiste
une concurrence saine éric bocquet
malgré tout la collectivité avant tout
selon vous l'intérêt général avant que
le vaccin comme les médicaments n'est
pas une marchandise comme une autre
c'est même pas une marchandise
cela tombait dans le domaine public
effectivement je voudrais rappeler les
anecdotes de ce biologiste américain
john à ce saut dans les années 60 celui
qui a découvert le vaccin contre la
poliomyélite
interrogé un jour sur une un plateau de
télévision on lui a demandé à qui serait
attribué le brevet et il a eu cette
réponse absolument formidable c'était
pas un communiste le gars il a dit ben
écoutez le brevet sera remis au peuple
est ce que le soleil doit faire l'objet
d'un brevet nous sommes en face d'une
épidémie historique jamais le monde a
été confronté à cette situation tous les
états sont percutés toutes les économies
toutes les nations d'ailleurs la demande
qui a été déposée par l'afrique du sud
et l'inde a été soutenue par les 100
pays les plus pauvres du monde
donc on est très loin d'une idée entre
guillemets communiste ça n'a rien à voir
il s'agit de l'intérêt général est ce
que le médicament est ce que le vaccin
doit d'être et de marchandises il faut
absolument lever les brevets mettre en
place la licence de vis ça existe dans
le code de la santé est dictée par le ms
il faut que les étapes poussent dans ce
sens il faut que le politique dans le
bon sens du terme reprennent la main sur
les affaires du monde
alors justement les politiques ont les
écoule 1 c2 on les écoute pardon c'est
de votre bord éric bocquet je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'en pense un le
premier secrétaire national de votre
parti le pcf fabien roussel à lille
comme dans toutes les régions de france
nous sommes mobilisés pour demander la
levée des brevets sur les vaccins contre
la copie 19 omc doit prendre une
décision de ces jours ci la france doit
soutenir la demande de l'afrique du sud
est de l'inde
la première partie on l'a compris vous
êtes pour la levée de ces brevets mais
ce que dit en gros fabien roussel c'est
que la france doit porter ce combat est
d'ailleurs l'appel de paris sa porte
bien son nom
était lancée aujourd'hui c'est pas un
petit peu gonflé là je me fais l'avocat
du diable mais pour la france qui n'a
produit aucun vaccin est facile de
demander à d'autres pays peut-être
qu'ils ont réussi qui ont investi des
milliards justement de produire et de
partage et surtout ce vaccin phillip r
là on imagine que ces pays vont pas
forcément bien réagir bah oui enfin mais
oui c'était encore plus souvent nous on
n'a même pas le vaccin parce que on a
des regrets sont pas suffisamment
performantes notamment parce qu'elles
sont écrasés par des impôts la france a
le taux de prêt obligatoire le plus
élevé du monde on est un
on est un pays pas communisme est
socialiste et on envoie les haltes à
tous les jours avec les désastres
l'imagination et qui est notamment le
fait qu'on n'ait pas vu qu'on n'a même
pas des gars de trouver un vaccin donc
la voie c'est pas deux évidemment si
c'est très facile d'aller d'aller piquer
le bang les brevets catégorie qui a été
fait pas de reprise étrangères pour le
ramener en france mais s'est passé de
façon là pour adresser l'économie bon
voilà quoi
et puis pour revenir sur la notion
d'intérêt général l'intérêt général
quand il définit uniquement par l'état
moi je me méfie moi je considère que
l'intérêt général et les citoyens ont le
droit de donner leur avis donc il faut
défendre la liberté d'expression et la
liberté de décision la liberté de
choisir plusieurs vaccins parce que si
si on si on vient notre modèle de
monsieur mba ce moment là il y aura un
vaccin promu par l'état et on n'a aucun
choix
moi ça me plaît pas moi je vais avoir le
choix enfin personnellement j'aime bien
vaccinés mais sur sierre région doit
avoir le choix de se faire vacciner
voilà et le brevet c'est quelque chose
de nécessaire pour développer
l'industrie
et puis il faut savoir aussi que le
brevet c'est pas éternel le brevet au
bout d'un moment ils tombent dans le
domaine public et à ce moment là il ya
les génériques et ce qui fait que la
plupart des maladies aujourd'hui peuvent
être soignés par des génériques c'est à
dire des brevets qui justement sont
retombés dans ma même public donc c'est
donc c'est quelque chose de très simple
tout à fait normal il faut pas qu'une
entreprise bénéficie éternellement de
son brevet donc c'est normal que ça
retombe dans le domaine public et
s'oblige d'entreprises va trouver
d'autres vagues d'autres médicaments et
d'autres vaccins
donc ça c'est un mécanisme de
concurrence très simple voilà donc
donc la plupart des médicaments en fait
ce sont aujourd'hui des génériques
et puis là les entreprises ont fait des
efforts énormes en très peu de temps
pour sortir des vaccins il est normal
qu'ils puissent toucher des revenus pour
ne serait-ce que le payer les chercheurs
qui ont travaillé parce que si on leur
pique le le les brevets maintenant avons
pu avoir de ressources donc comment
comment ils vont payer les licences les
moissons de largeur on a compris l'idée
philippe herlin éric bocquet sur cet
argument il faut bien payer les
chercheurs et justement que peut-être
ses laboratoires qui n'ont pas toujours
bonne presse et on peut comprendre les
raisons il faut bien je sens qui se
rémunèrent de façon peut-être trouvé
voilà d'autres vaccins et puis
d'ailleurs pas que contre le coc vide
mais contre le cancer vous faites quoi
tu sais tu ce dernier argument
écoutez moi je vais quand même rappeler
ici que le crédit d'impôt recherche en
france qui représente une dépense de 6
milliards d'euros par an dont un groupe
comme sanofi a bénéficié par centaines
et millions d'euros et l'on constate que
sur la période le groupe sanofi envisage
de supprimer 400 postes de chercheurs et
a fait le choix de rémunérer grassement
les dividendes des actionnaires
quand je parlais tout à l'heure d'une
marchandise c'est ça que j'avais en tête
est-ce qu'on est en face ici d'un
produit marchand comme des chaussettes
il du dentifrice
on est en face à vaccin que tout le
monde attend ça fait un an que nous dans
la pandémie la seule issue pour sa télé
ces crises économique sociale et
maintenant psychologique c'est la
vaccination sur un plan très très large
d'où l'intérêt de lever les brevets nous
avons les capacités en france de
produire ces vaccins je constate
malheureusement aujourd'hui aucun vaccin
est produit dans ce pays le pays de
pasteur c'est quand même absolument
sidérant l'espagne en produits la
belgique en produits l'allemagne n'en
produit le royaume uni en produit est
d'ailleurs réalisé une performance
exceptionnelle en matière de vaccination
s'est pas fatal il n'y a aucune fatalité
à ça donc il ya l'argent public qui a
servi aussi à aider les groupes
pharmaceutiques français qui aujourd'hui
ne sont pas au rendez vous de la
vaccination est votre réponse philippe
herlin pourquoi la france ne produit pas
de vaccin comme ça je suis d'accord que
sanofi gia par sanofi c'est un échec
énorme faim le fait que la france n'est
pas près du lac sainte anne et c'est
énorme mais la solution c'est pas des
piquets des brevets aux entreprises
étrangères la solution c'est de faire en
sorte que l'économie française soit plus
performante
ça s'inscrit dans une tendance générale
est la désindustrialisation à une fuite
des cerveaux aussi et ça c'est des
problèmes français que l'on connaît et
qui tiennent notamment au fait qu'il ya
trop de charges qui pèsent selon de
crise alors les s'est hissé au sommet on
va pas on va bien c'est un débat trop
libéral et antilibéral mai mais quand
même parce que l'argument voilà de ceux
qui veulent la levée de ce vaccin c'est
d'augmenter aussi la production est ce
qu'il y aurait pas des chances
d'augmenter la production de ce vaccin
parce que là on est en train de parler
derrière de partager le brevet enfin en
attendant on n'arrive pas à produire
assez soucié tous les pays se mettent
justement à à produire parce que les
brevets sont libérés est ce qu'on n'aura
pas ça va bénéficier à tous les états
finalement moi je crois que si on n'a
pas assez de vaccins c'est parce qu'on a
voulu c'est parce qu'elle venait de
macron a absolument voulu passer par
l'union européenne qui est une bourreau
craties copenhague efficace et qui s'est
complètement plantée dans l'achat des
vaccins il y aura ma musique la france
s'occupe d'acheter des vaccins
et comme l'a fait l'angleterre juste
avant et on en aurait beaucoup plus si
on peut vacciner beaucoup plus de monde
voilà c'est ça la cause du problème
aujourd'hui en france on n'a pris aucune
responsabilité on s'est reposé sur la
bureaucratie européenne
eh ben on voit le résultat éric bocquet
est ce que vous n'allez pas trop vite
avec votre proposition père score on l'a
vu tous les vaccins ne font pas
consensus ans et le moins qu'on puisse
dire aujourd'hui
l'astra zeneca et suspendu en norvège au
danemark en islande alors pas en france
pour l'instant votre demande
au pcf c'est quoi de de lever tous les
brevets ou d'enlever seulement un
certain mais l'urgence de l'urgence est
hélas l'urgence l'urgence et les
sanitaires aujourd'hui monsieur-là que
je respecte
me pas l'économie et conclure
ans moi je parle santé vie et l'humain
qu'est ce que vous voulez on a deux
logiques en face mais c'est tout à fait
créé l'attendait ce qui est en train de
se passer
on a servi des dividendes chez sanofi et
on a supprimé des bois c'est le
chercheur est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de payer aussi ses choix
stratégiques de ce grand groupe
pharmaceutique
quand on est quand même sixième
puissance économique du monde
on n'est pas un pays de second rang on
n'est pas les meilleurs du monde me
donnait des capacités intellectuelles
industriels et scientifiques de produire
les choses que moi je n'accepte pas que
la france ait cette situation
aujourd'hui il ne doit rien à la
fatalité
la conséquence de choix économiques que
monsieur r là un partage je respecte
mais je ne je ne partage pas promeut
encore aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation d'urgence il faut vacciner les
gens sur une grande échelle
la question c'est celle là alors en tout
cas les français sont favorables à cette
idée regardez le résultat de ce sondage
oxfam france 70% c'est beaucoup estiment
que le partage devrait être obligatoire
oxfam qui dit que ça n'a aucun sens de
maintenir un contrôle exclusif de
quelques grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques sur la production
philippe herlin votre réponse l'oxfam
aucun sens de maintenir le contrôle
exclusif sur quelques entreprises de
production pas d'avoir toujours dire
c'est un peu facile de dire que les
côtés de l'humain quand l'adversaire
allait coûter de l'argent parce que
c'est quand même le capitalisme et le
libéralisme ont permis de développer
l'économie et un système de santé
performant en europe et en occident on
va la première chose par rapport aux
sondages d'oxfam bon on sait que les
sondages sont un peu déterminé par celui
qui le commande
oxfam est une officine écologistes et
gauchistes donc c'est pas le résultat
n'est pas étonnant ensuite que les
français qu'une partie des français sont
favorables à cette idée bas on leur
présente ça comme ce sera mieux et moins
cher donc a priori ils disent oui mais
je pense que si on leur expliquait
vraiment les tenants et les aboutissants
le fait qu'il faut investir pour trouver
des vaccins que ça tombe pas du ciel
et puis que si l'état contre toute la
production comme des régimes communistes
eh ben ça marche pas du tout et puis aux
filles au final dans l'est j'ai une
copine ici avec eux des pénuries donc et
comme la france est socialiste est bon
on a régime de pénurie voilà donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut sortir de cette
logique et aller vers plus de liberté
économique et de liberté en général
éric bocquet le mot de la fin mozafar
écouté hier j'ai eu une rencontre hier
au sénat ce qui arrive avec
l'ambassadeur de cuba qui nous
expliquait qu'il y avait cinq vaccin
actuellement en mana lice à cuba pour
lancer la campagne de vaccination vous
avez le droit d'avoir les idées que vous
avez que je ne partage pas mais
franchement le débat est un peu
caricatural encore une fois l'urgence
c'est de déployer la vaccination à
grande échelle
quand d'autres pays qui ne sont pas des
pays communistes le fonds est prêt
devrait s'inspirer de leurs stratégies
aussi relâche que je voulais venir
maëlys qu'yvan abonnés ça c'est sûr ça
c'est sûr cuba est un modèle c'est sûr
merci à vous on vous mettra pas d'accord
c'était pas de bus c'était un face à
face et d'affronter donc des idées
différentes merci en tous les cas tous
les deux éric bocquet et philippe herlin
d'avoir été avec nous est l'une des
conséquences de l'épidémie de kobe 19
beaucoup d'étudiants ont sombré dans la
précarité sont de plus en plus nombreux
à pousser les portes des banques
alimentaires une détresse qui ne laisse
pas indifférent les patrons de
discothèques pourtant eux-mêmes en
grande difficulté à aix-en-provence
certains d'entre eux ont même décidé de
leur venir en aide reportage isabelle
ferrière avec maxime abolin vous avez
été là pour nous hier nous sommes là
pour vous aujourd'hui c'est par ce
slogan que la boîte de nuit le mistral à
aix en provence a ouvert ses portes aux
étudiants ce mercredi lancé par le
collectif des discothèques de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur et de corse
cet événement d'une initiative pour
venir en aide aux jeunes qui souffrent
eux aussi de la crise sanitaire
objectif distribuer des paniers repas
gratuit seule condition être détenteur
d'une carte d'étudiant
les étudiants sont nos promos nos
principaux clients
donc on a trouvé ça normal et on le fait
vraiment de mon coeur de avec nos moyens
d'essayer de la rendre service si on
peut leur apporter un petit quelque
chose en plus c'est vraiment très
important et ça nous fait très plaisir
outre les denrées alimentaires les
élèves ont également pu profiter des
services de praticiens de santi
également bénévole donc ils sont proposé
de venir s'ils peuvent soutenir aider
qui a des sophrologues il y à des
psychologues
il ya des thérapeutes il ya des
ostéopathes tout ça bénévolement pour
pouvoir un donner un petit coup de pouce
et mettre leur pierre à l'édifice
une première opération avait déjà attiré
près de 150 étudiants
je suis vraiment reconnaissant d'être
ici franchement c'est un très bonne idée
parce que ya beaucoup étudiante qui ne
qui ne connais pas du tout cette
association existe donc c'est cette
importance et c'est vraiment essentiel
tout nous en fait c'est surtout super ce
gratuit parce que nous les étudiants
financièrement aujourd'hui ce compliqué
et c'est vrai que j'ai compris du coup
avec cette séance d'ostéopathie que
toutes nos angoisses pourrait se
répercuter sur le fonctionnement de
notre corps
donc il fallait enfin pour moi c'était
une évidence fallait que j'aille
l'accueil positif des étudiants à même
le mistral et ses bénévoles à réitérer
cette opération
le collectif souhaite désormais proposer
cet événement au moins deux fois par
mois
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'espagne qui compte
sur son passeport vaccinale pour sauver
sa saison touristique cet été
le gouvernement se prépare et puis
direction l'italie où l'inquiétude règne
elle est varié en anglais brésil elle
circule de plus en plus le pays pourrait
être confiné partiellement
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara en confiance
la france comme l'europe a été absente
de l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume
humain des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifique
[Musique]
et
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï kg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
non
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce jardin barre de la et marion
maréchal-le pen qui dénonce cette
censure pour eux facebook menaçant fait
de publier des pages de soutien
mouvement génération identitaire il faut
en finir avec cette dérive dégâts femmes
il faut rappeler la primauté du droit
français sur le territoire national des
pouvoirs publics en france et dans
d'autres pays sont un peu tétanisé face
aux géants du numérique
moi j'ai eu l'occasion il ya quelques il
ya deux ans au parlement européen d'
intervenez mark zuckerberg le pdg de
facebook sur cette question il avait
d'ailleurs répondu de manière très
alambiquée mais je crois que ça
nécessite maintenant que les pouvoirs
publics se saisissent du sujet ils
défendent la liberté d'expression et
s'ils ne le font pas et bien esprits
pour
[Musique]
et
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata pas par an
pathamathan vous avez envie de faire ça
mais il faut que leur qu'istres groove
la musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
un 20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez en espagne le
passeport vaccinale pourrait être prêt
pour mai prochain
dans une interview à la télévision
espagnole la ministre du tourisme
reyes maroteaux indiqué que le
gouvernement se penchait sérieusement
sur la question les explications de
leslie singh là notre correspondante à
barcelone absolument l'espagne souhaite
d'être pionnière du passeport vaccinale
le gouvernement ambitionne de le sortir
le plus tôt possible mais il a reconnu
qu'il faudrait que le passeport
vaccinale s'adapte à l'évolution de la
pandémie alors toutefois ce que
contiendrait ce certificat restent
encore floues il y aurait des
discussions au sein même du gouvernement
pour certains il devrait présenter les
résultats de tests pcr pour d'autres le
test pcr pourrait être remplacé par un
carnet de vaccination mais certains
secteurs juge cette option
trop risqué dans tous les cas le
gouvernement espagnol misé sur une
campagne de vaccination qui avance bien
le pays approche les 5 millions de doses
distribuées et il ya plus de sept pour
cent de la population qui a été vaccinée
alors ces chiffres permettent au
gouvernement de planifier l'activation
du passeport vaccinale et il a même
annoncé une date le 19 mai jour de
l'inauguration de la foire du tourisme à
madrid ça pourrait être une renaissance
pour le secteur la ministre espagnole du
tourisme se montre très confiante je
vous propose de l'écouter
nous travaillons pour la voir ou plutôt
il faut que les gens aient la certitude
que le gouvernement espagnol est en
train de travailler pour ouvrir le
tourisme mais le faire en toute sécurité
attirer à nouveau les visiteurs devient
une priorité pour l'espagne le pays
accuse une baisse de 77% de touristes en
2020 alors que le secteur représente 12
% de l'économie espagnole et pour en
parler nous sommes avec philippe
emmanueli médecins français exerçant en
espagne bonsoir
nelly merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce passeport le
gouvernement espagnol en rêve
manifestement et vous en tant que
médecin eh bien écoutez vieux rêve à la
réalité il ya toujours une distance et
c'est vrai quand on n'arrive pas bien
savoir à imaginer ce que seront les
contours de ce fameux passeport
vaccinale parce qu'on s'est d'une part
que les et les touristes vacciner
pourront quand même effectivement
transporté le virus et d'autre part
effectivement on voit mal un passeport
vaccinale s'affranchir des tests pcr
pour l'épauler pour les futurs voyageurs
donc c'est vrai que bon entre le rêve
effectivement d'un passeport universel
qui permettrait effectivement de revenir
à la normalité et la réalité des
problèmes techniques qui vont se poser
pour ce passeport est bien il ya quand
même une différence cette année votre
téléphone
on ne connaît pas encore son contenu
effectivement pcr vous l'avez dit carnet
de vaccination il ya des divisions au
sein du gouvernement vous pour vous
quelle serait la meilleure solution
écoutez pour moi je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de solution idéale
nous sommes en chemin vers la
vaccination massive de la population et
on sait que quand on aura atteint un
certain pourcentage de la population
vaccinée on peut espérer effectivement
effectué en une espèce de 2,2 d'épidémie
qui qui s'étendrait et qui permettrait
de revenir peut-être la normalité avec
des contaminations sporadiques mais
quand à trouver une solution
administrative un problème effectivement
épidémiologique
je pense que la route est encore longue
alors en france on a vu il ya certains
responsables gouvernementaux qui ont
lancé l'idée ça a été évidemment repris
avec pas mal de critiques sur le thème
des libertés individuelles pas ce type
de débat en espagne
comment accueillir et la population
cette initiative
ici nous sommes à quelques semaines
maintenant de la semaine à santa qui est
un petit peu là le lancement de la
saison printanière et estivale et donc
ici tous les tous les regards et toutes
les attentions se sont dirigés vers
l'ouverture cette nouvelle saison est
donc le temps n'est pas à la polémique
mais à l'espoir et tout le monde ici
espère pouvoir retrouver une saison à
peu près normale enfin cette année alors
cela passera on le dit dans tous les
pays par la vaccination comment se passe
la vaccination justement vous en tant
que médecin est ce qu'au sein de votre
cabinet vous vacciner des espagnols
toute la journée
alors moi je ne vaccinent pas parce que
le vaccin raisons de logistique en fait
et distribué uniquement dans les centres
de santé publics et cette vaccination
effectivement il se passe très bien
puisque sur 5,5 millions vaccin qui a
reçu à ce jour l'espagne et bien elle en
a administré cinq millions c'est dire si
effectivement le circuit logistique
fonctionne bien et c'est vrai que
personne ne se plaint ici du déroulement
de la vaccination personne sauf
peut-être justement les expatriés car
tous ceux effectivement qui ne sont pas
inscrits au niveau du système public
espagnol n'ont pas accès aujourd'hui au
vaccin ce qui correspond quand même un
nombre important d'expatriés français
alors justement en france on se plaint
les médecins comme vous se plaignent à
un grosse colère des médecins olivier
verront leur a d'ailleurs répondu hier
soir parce qu'ils ont finalement
transféré les vaccins aux pharmaciens
pour qu'ils puissent vacciner à partir
du 15 mars pour vous c'est clair la
situation pas de pharmaciens pas de
médecins uniquement des gros centres de
vaccination ici c'est pas vraiment des
gros centres c'est à dire qu'ils
utilisent le système de santé tels
qu'ils existent et c'est vrai que le
système espagnol est un système très
administrée donc ce système là j'allais
dire est assez idéal pour les campagnes
de prévention de masse pour les
campagnes de vaccination de masse c'est
un système qui fait ses preuves dans ce
type de situation mais a contrario tout
n'est pas rose c'est à dire que ces
systèmes qui met en oeuvre cette
vaccination avec effectivement des taux
effectivement de vaccination très
satisfaisant et bien par ailleurs sont
saturés pour ce qui concerne la médecine
générale de tous les jours pour les
soins de tous les jours et c'est vrai
qu'on entend effectivement un certain
nombre de patients se plaint de ne plus
pouvoir accéder au centre pour des
pathologies habituelles l arrivée vers
ont exprimé ce soir enfants son
inquiétude quant aux variantes plus
contagieux plus dangereux en français
65% des cas qu'en est-il en espagne vous
partager la même crainte ici on espère
vendre à de très bons chiffres
c'est-à-dire qu'on arrive à une
incidence qui est de l'ordre de voiliers
133 1000 cas pour 100000 habitants ce
qui est ce qui est ce qui est vraiment
très
raisonnable puisque l'objectif avoué
épidémiologiquement et de revenir vers
environ une incidence de 50 pour cent
mille habitants
donc on sent bien qu'on en est pas loin
et tout cela avec des mesures qui
auraient été beaucoup plus souple qu'en
france donc les les résultats sur le
terrain sont vraiment bons pour autant
le variant anglais neuneu n'a pas encore
je dirais la même importance qu en
france et donc il se pourrait qu'on ait
des surprises dans dans le mois qui
vient ses surprises été annoncée pour la
fin du mois de mars
donc peut-être que la situation peut
évoluer dans les quelques semaines qui
viennent faire à suivre donc merci
philippe emmanuel i nous avoir fait part
de cette situation en espagne merci à
vous merci bonsoir bonsoir et en italie
la situation sanitaire continue de
susciter l'inquiétude là bas aussi en
ligne de mire la lutte livrée aux
variants anglais on vient d'en parler et
brésiliens ducobu 19 qui circule de plus
en plus le gouvernement devrait signer
ce vendredi un nouveau décret confinant
partiellement le territoire ont fait le
point avec t il à saraf une situation
sanitaire qui s'est brutalement dégradé
en italie dans tout le pays les
contaminations repartent à la hausse
depuis trois semaines avec plus de 20000
cas par jour d'après les derniers bilans
le nombre de malades en soins intensifs
est aussi en augmentation permanente
la thérapie est toujours la même
les symptômes sont les mêmes l'agent
pathogène c'est à dire la gravité de la
maladie est similaire au virus normale
ce qui change c'est la contagiosité
la transmission se fait plus facilement
sommes souvent confrontés à l'arrivée de
familles entières épouse marie père et
fils
l'autre aspect principal à souligner est
que l'âge est abaissée cela n'affecte
pas principalement les personnes âgées
il ya aussi les plus jeunes de 40 à 50
ans nous avons de nombreux patients
hospitalisés entre
35 et 55 ans le variant britannique est
désormais majoritaire et semble avoir
bien progressé pendant la période qui
correspond à l'assouplissement des
restrictions la réouverture de certains
cinémas et théâtres qui devait avoir
lieu le 27 mars semble désormais
compromise l'objectif ce serait ça
peut-être recombiner certaines régions
ou les remettre des zones un peu plus
rouge un peu plus tripette un couvre-feu
peut-être plus tôt en italie mais dans
l'objectif d'accélérer au maximum et que
pour le mois d'avril et bien l'italie
serait quasi libérer de ce problème donc
il ya vraiment un sentiment est un désir
de la part du gouvernement et du de la
santé sperenza d'accélérer fortement et
que tu avril soit le mois de la
vaccination
en attendant l'éclaircie tout semble
indiquer un prochain tour de vis parmi
les pistes envisagées par le comité
technique aux scientifiques italiens un
retour en zone rouge du pays entier
durant les week-ends avec la fermeture
des bars et des restaurants ainsi que le
confinement total pour les villes ou
régions le seuil de 250 contamination
hebdomadaire pour 100000 habitants est à
temps la pandémie officiellement
déclarées comme telles par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé il y
a tout juste un an c'était le 11 mars
dernier l'om est critiqué pour avoir
donné l alerte trop tard aujourd'hui
l'organisation se défend le récit de
quentin mots clairs et médias ce qui fit
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
at-elle trop tardé pour tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé
le 11 mars 2020 l'om est qualifié pour
la première fois la situation sanitaire
de pandémie un an plus tard des
critiques émergent sur le temps mis par
l'institution pour alerter le monde au
début de la crise sanitaire
de hauts responsables se défendent et
pointe du doigt certains pays qui aurait
fait sourde oreille shoah et funk
donc je pense que nous devons nous
demander si nous devons peut-être crier
plus fort mais peut-être que certains
ont besoin d'un appareil auditif pas si
nous faisons de notre mieux pour
informer chaque jour sur la situation à
former le monde sur ce que l'on savait
de ce virus sur les dangers de ce virus
et dire dès le départ qu'il s'agissait
de
virus dangereux c'est que les systèmes
d'urgence sanitaire devait être activée
les premiers cas de kovy 19 ont été
recensés en décembre 2019 à wuhan en
chine
pour autant le 23 janvier 2020 l' oms ne
recommande et je cite aucune mesure
sanitaire particulière concernant les
voyageurs une semaine plus tard
l'institution décrète l' alerte mondiale
la propagation du virus s'accélère et
l'institution qualifie la situation de
pandémie si près d'un mois et demi plus
tard le 11 mars 2020 d'après joe louis
bès et évaluer cette pandémie 24 heures
sur 24 et nous sommes profondément
préoccupés à la fois par les niveaux
alarmants de propagation et de gravité
ainsi que par les niveaux alarmants
d'inaction nous avons estimé que la
crise du coc u19 peut être caractérisé
comme une pandémie
vient ensuite la question des masques
jusqu'au 5 juin dernier lot et metz ne
recommandait pas le port du masque dans
l'espace public tout en laissant le soin
aux états d'évaluer leur situation et
les risques au cas par cas
c'est d'ailleurs sur la base de leur
absence de recommandations que la porte
parole du gouvernement s'ils battent
ndiaye se basait en avril 2020 je suis
les recommandations qui sont en vigueur
nous prendrons une décision pour
l'éventuelle extension du port du masque
dans toute la population dès lors que
nous pourrons la bâtir sur un consensus
scientifique
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de consensus
scientifique en la matière cette crise
sanitaire a également été l'objet de
tensions entre les états unis et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé en
juillet dernier si donald trump claqué
la porte de l'institution lui reprochant
d'avoir minimisé l'ampleur de la
pandémie
dès son élection joe biden est quant à
lui revenu sur cette décision
un choix apprécié du côté de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
nous nous félicitons de l'engagement du
président biden à ne pas se contenter
seulement de réintégrer
la famille de l' oms elle met aussi à
travailler de manière constructive avec
le msc états membres et le système
multilatéral pour mettre fin à la
pandémie et relever les nombreux défis
sanitaires auxquels nous sommes
confrontés dans le monde avec l'ampleur
de cette crise sanitaire
l' oms pourrait commencer à se réformer
dans les mois à venir en janvier un
groupe d'experts indépendant appelé à
apporter des changements au sein de
l'institution aux états unis est présent
1900 milliards de dollars c'est le
montant du plan de relance économique
signé ce soit pas joe biden au lendemain
de son adoption par le congrès américain
baptisé plan de sauvetage américain
c'est une victoire majeure pour le
président le pr la première depuis son
arrivée à la maison blanche
ce plan colossal doit entre autres
inclure de nouvelles mesures de soutien
aux ménages aux petites entreprises et
aux autorités locales ainsi qu une aide
directe aux américains il comprend
également des mesures de lutte contre la
pauvreté et un plan également tournés
vers la lutte contre le coc vie 19 ce
dernier va permettre de financer la
campagne de vaccination contre le virus
et l'achat de fournitures médicales
écoute je n'ai pas hésité à utiliser les
pouvoirs qui me sont conférés par la loi
sur la production de défense pour
accélérer l'approvisionnement en
matériaux essentiels à la production de
vaccins tels que les équipements les
machines et le matériel
le résultat est que nous sommes en passe
de disposer d'un stock de vaccins
suffisant pour chaque adulte américains
d'ici la fin du mois de mai et
aujourd'hui je demande à jeff et à mon
équipe santé de produire 100 millions de
doses supplémentaires et d'acheter 100
millions de doses supplémentaires du
vaccin de johnson and johnson pour
parler de ce plan nous sommes en direct
depuis las vegas avec guy millière
chercheur au gates taunts qt hauteur de
après trompe aux éditions balland c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir guy millière merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france un plan
montant vertigineux l'équivalent du pib
de l'italie ça y est joe biden vient de
le signer il fait la part belle à la
lutte contre la pandémie c'est en tout
cas ce que présente à ce que disent les
démocrates est ce que c'est vraiment le
cas puisque les républicains disent que
seuls 9 % de ce plan est dédié à la
lutte contre l'épidémie se lisent les
républicains et patrick mantez exact il
n'ya seulement 9 % de tous ces
astronomes hic qui est consacrée à la
lutte contre le coc vide
le reste de l'argent et pour partie de
l'argent qui va être effectivement
distribués aux familles ça va être
distribuée de manière très très
indistincte je dirais que la somme de
1400 $ qui est prévue va être donné à
des gens qui en ont réellement besoin
des gens qui sont dans les difficultés à
des gens qui sont au chômage
mais c'est un va être également
distribuées à des gens qui n'en n'ont
aucunement besoin par exemple si je
prends mon cas personnel je n'en ai pas
besoin je vais recevoir 2800 $ pour moi
et pour mon épouse nous n'en avons pas
besoin donc je dirais que c'est de
l'argent inutilement distribués et puis
le plus grave dans tout cela c'est que
l'essentiel de l'argent qui est inclus
dans ce plan va servir à renflouer des
états qui sont dans des difficultés
économiques financières parce qu'ils ont
été mal géré il était à new york l état
de californie par exemple
et cet argent et de l'argent qui va être
très très largement gaspiller et le
point le plus grave dans cet argent
c'est que cet argent relève de ce que
l'on peut appeler une relance par la
demande de type keynésien en effet on va
faire tourner la planche à billets on va
mettre beaucoup plus d'argent en
circulation cela ne peut que conduire à
de l'inflation d'ailleurs l'inflation a
déjà commencé quand on met beaucoup plus
d'argent en circulation que ce qui
pourrait correspondre à l'augmentation
de la masse monétaire correspond à
l'augmentation
du produit intérieur brut c'est ce qui
se passe et je dirais que c'est d'autant
plus grave que ça se passe dans un
contexte joue alors que avant l'arrivée
de baden avant l'élection ne pas y donne
il y avait une économie qui était en
train de repartir
beaucoup de décisions qui ont été prises
par l'administration by donne sont des
décisions qui sont contraires à la
possibilité pour les entreprises
d'investir et qui au contraire sont très
négatives pour les investissements donc
on en abyme l'offre en détériore l'offre
et en même temps on injecte de l'argent
pour la demande
je dirais que cela ne cibler et trop de
dettes
oui bien sur la dette va augmenter gérée
clé la plupart des économistes
américains pensent qu'à la fin de la
présidence byetone au bout de quatre ans
il y aura environ 11 trillions de
dollars de plus de dette américaine ce
qui est absolument considérable et ceci
dans un contexte où on va détériorer
l'appareil productif américain je dirais
que ça a commencé dès le premier jour où
joe biden a été élu puisqu'il a décidé
d'arrêter le questionne park lane mais
d'arrêter l'exploitation de gaz et de
pétrole de schiste sur les terres
fédérales
ce sont des décisions très négative
économiquement qui ont été prises de
cette façon là donc compenser ces
décisions négatives économiquement par
de la distribution d'argent qu'on n'a
pas en faisant tourner la planche à
billets ce n'est pas une façon de
construire une économie très saine et je
dirais que beaucoup de gens parlent de
victoire et sans triomphalisme dans le
contexte français
je dirais c'est pas du tout une épique
soir c'est pas du tout triomphalisme
rien de triomphaliste a proclamé
l'économie américaine il ya un an était
la plus saine que le pays ait connu
depuis 50 ans la croissance au troisième
trimestre de l'année 2020 et est reparti
dans le rythme record de 33 8% en rythme
annuel donc les états unis n'aient pas
besoin d'un sauvetage économique
ils avaient besoin d'un retour au
dynamisme plein et entier de l'appareil
productif et je dirais que ce qui est
sain pour une population
c'est le plein emploi c'est d'avoir des
emplois ch ça n'est pas de recevoir des
subventions du gouvernement qui devait
recenser subvention de l'argent qu'il
doit prier parce qu'il n'y a que toi ce
plan est aussi est présenté comme un
plan de lutte contre la pauvreté inédit
depuis des années 60
certains se diront plutôt une bonne
nouvelle et un plan louable un pour les
plus pauvres et il n'y en a évidemment
plein aux états unis et aux états unis
surtout après cette pandémie
je dirais que la pauvreté a augmenté
pendant la pandémie le chômage aussi le
chemin jeu à l'automne dernier était en
train de reculer très très nettement et
je dirais que si les choses s'étaient
poursuivies sur cette lancée au deuxième
trimestre à 1021 je pense qu'on ne voie
était de retour aux états unis au plein
emploi qui existait au mois de mars de
l'an dernier là nous ne serons pas dans
cette situation la pauvreté était aussi
un train de reculer la pauvreté avait
considérablement reculé pendant les
années train elle a remonté très
fortement parce qu'il ya toutes les
fermetures occasionnés par la pandémie
mais je les avais que la meilleure façon
de faire reculer la pauvreté
c'est d'avoir une économie en croissance
c'est d'avoir des entreprises qui
investissent c'est d'avoir des
entreprises dynamiques
c'est d'avoir des emplois qui se créent
ce n'est pas de distribuer de l'argent
qu'on n'a pas c'est une situation très
très malsaine qui secret quand on
distribue l'argent qu'on à pas et c'est
hélas ce que paie d'administration byden
dans ce moment très rapidement guy
millière joe biden a annoncé avec aussi
cet argent l'achat de 100 millions de
doses de vaccins supplémentaires c
et quand même de quoi sortir les états
unis du marasme a quant à cette pandémie
selon vont tout de même
et actuellement les ondes et demi est en
train de s'effacer d'ailleurs je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui doit prendre
forme aussi en europe
vous avez de plus en plus d'états aux
états unis où on a levé toutes les
fermetures tout une toutes les mesures
de confinement
on a levé l'obligation du port du masque
et jeudi reste un gourou qui va se
répandre qu'il va faire tache d'huile et
jetterait qu'un si je regarde la
situation à las vegas ou jeudi les
spectacles sont interrompues mais la
plupart des entreprises ont recommencé à
tourner les restaurants tourne à 50% de
leurs capacités
on est en fin de pandémie actuellement
et j'ajouterai que ceux qui auraient été
les gants de la part de joe biden c'est
de dire qu'une large partie de l'idée
des avancées pour la lutte contre le
coronavirus qu'il s'attribue avait été
mise en place sous donald trump
si les vaccins existent c'est parce que
donald trump avait lancé une opération
qui s'appelle world speed c'est grâce à
cette opération que les vaccins existent
et la distribution de vaccins étaient
totalement connues par l'administration
trempe et donc joe biden bénéficient des
acquis de l'administration top mais il
attend de l'élégance de lui dire merci
gimme des chercheurs aux gets en
institut hauteur de après trois éditions
balland et partisan de
donald trump mercier en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous reviendrons sur la
prise de parole tout à l'heure d'olivier
véran l'île de france inquiète
particulièrement
toutes les 12 minutes 8 et jour un
francilien est admis en réanimation des
dizaines voire des centaines de patients
pourraient être transférés et puis nous
parlerons de la commémoration du
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
si un hommage à cette figure de
l'histoire de france est prévue le 5 mai
cette question divise pourtant notamment
les politiques
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont conquis a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos j'ai
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout un questionnement
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
et
freiner le réchauffement climatique tout
en stimulant la croissance voici
grossièrement la finalité de ce que l'on
appelle communément la relance verte
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
relance verte quand vous avez une
économie qui est entièrement mondialisée
c'est des mots c'est de la com c'est non
seulement indispensable mais c'est une
condition de survie à moyen long terme
de l'espèce humaine
le premier grand sujet c'est de réduire
les âges du pétrole et du gaz bromont
gestes quotidiens
oui il faudrait faire quelque chose mais
on ne s'en donne absolument pas les
moyens et on n'a pas du tout envie même
bill gates te dire son dernier bouquin
aucune trajectoire n'est possible si on
réunit pas notre consommation d'énergie
monsieur le maire nous explique qu'on va
rembourser toutes leurs bêtises avec une
croissance exceptionnellement forte je
voudrais qu'on m'explique comment on va
arriver à baisser la consommation
d'énergie et faire 6% de croissance de
l'autre côté ça va être compliqué
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime pour qu'on parle de jay liste
on parle de gens qui recrutent des
enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême cerexhe est un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un an qu'il y en a qui
sont embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils
ont été manipulés et d'autres qui
agissent de manière parfaitement
consciente et lucide je respecterai
toujours l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
m
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va de suicide et
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gars fall ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et non line quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for bouclé gaza s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dole à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts même
les citoyens on est une société qui est
totalement a percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde est
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 11 mars
les variants plus dangereux et plus
contagieux il représente plus de deux
tiers des contaminations en france prise
de parole tout à l'heure d'olivier
veyrat qui n'a pas caché son inquiétude
notamment concernant l'île de france des
dizaines voire des centaines de patients
pourraient être transférés côté vaccins
pas de suspension d'astrazeneca comme
c'est le cas au danemark en norvège ou
en islande
johnson & johnson validé par l'europe
c'est le quatrième sérum à lettres
manuel mettront à commémorera bien le
bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon ce
sera le 5 mai prochain
mais si l'empereur est une figure
tutélaire de l'histoire de france
personnages préférés des français il est
aussi une figure controversée qui a
contre lui aujourd'hui les
anticolonialistes les antimilitaristes
et des féministes
alors qu'elle napoléon célébrer nous en
parlerons avec nos invités
[Musique]
et si emprunter devenait plus cher
depuis peu les taux d'intérêts remonte
sur les marchés ce qui laisse craindre
un renchérissement du crédit la partie
des états unis le phénomène commence à
gagner l'europe dans quelle mesure cette
remontée des taux est elle un danger
pour les entreprises et des ménages les
plus endettés autant de questions
auxquelles l'économiste jacques sapir
tentera de répondre dans son édito échos
[Musique]
le traditionnel point presse du ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand qui a
détaillé les dernières annonces incluant
notamment la prolongation du confinement
le week-end dans le dunkerquois et les
alpes maritimes
il a également évoqué la situation
tendue en ile de france ont fait le
point avec grégoire dont c'est
l'exécutif sur la corde raide
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
est revenu sur la situation critique en
ile-de-france région dans laquelle des
mesures de confinement reste pour le
moment écartée malgré des indicateurs
préoccupants pour éviter d'en arriver là
la stratégie de transfert massif de
patients va s'étendre dans le territoire
francilien la situation épidémique et
sanitaires en ile de france nous
préoccupent tout particulièrement
même si la tendance est un peu moins
forte depuis quelques jours l'incidence
la circulation du virus y est élevé 350
mille trois cent cinquante quatre pour
cent mille habitants
ils sont enregistrées en moyenne chaque
semaine et dansait déjà nous préparons
des transferts importants de patients
vers les autres régions qui pourrait
avoir lieu dès cette fin de semaine
quand je dis important c'est qu'on parle
là de dizaines voire voire de centaines
de patients qui pourraient être évacués
de l'île de france vers d'autres
hôpitaux d'autres régions du territoire
national la donne pourrait toutefois
changer si la pression devenait trop
forte sur les hôpitaux les autorités
pourraient alors appliqué aux
franciliens des mesures telles que
celles imposées aux habitants du
dunkerquois et des alpes maritimes
le ministre de la santé qui a fait un
point sur le variant britannique devenu
majoritaire a réalisé un bilan à date
concernant la campagne de vaccination
les variantes sont de fait plus
contagieux que le coc vite 19 classique
et le remplacent progressivement la part
de variants dit britannique est
supérieure à 60 7% et la part des
variants dit sud africain et brésilien
elle est bien contrôlée et maîtrisée
puisque elle reste aux alentours de 6%
en 24 heures
286 milles français ont reçu une
injection de vaccin c'est un record
depuis le début de notre campagne de
vaccination au total ce sont ainsi
quatre millions cinq cent quarante cinq
mille français qui ont reçu une première
injection et 2 millions 165 mille
français qui ont reçu leurs deux
injections
le gouvernement compte donc plus que
jamais sur l'efficacité de la
vaccination de masse pour éclaircir
l'horizon sanitaires alors qu'un nouveau
remède celui de johnson and johnson
vient d'être autorisée dans l'union
européenne
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric lapostolle professeur de
médecine d'urgence au samu 93 bonsoir
felitta post merci d'être avec nous
alors pas que des nouvelles
réjouissantes toutes les 12 minutes
nuitées jour un francilien est admis en
réanimation
c'est vrai que dit comme ça on prend la
mesure de la réalité
comment on va pouvoir gérer ce fut de
passion peu de patients en ile-de-france
alors la première chose qu'il faut se
dire c'est qu'il ya une hétérogénéité en
seine saint denis par exemple
alors où j'ai quitté le service il y
avait aucune place de réanimation pour
les patients qu'ovide à l'autre de
l'autre côté de l'île de france si on va
dans les yvelines
par contre il ya un taux d'incidence qui
est quasiment moitié moindre et plus de
lits donc ça oblige déjà dès aujourd'hui
à réaliser en fait des transferts c'est
à dire que tous les patients de
seine-saint-denis qui sont atteints par
le cos vide et qui doivent être
hospitalisés en réanimation sont
hospitalisés loin de la seine saint
denis et jusqu'à l'autre bout des
yvelines donc les transferts à
l'intérieur de la région sont déjà la
seule soupape de sécurité dont on
dispose actuellement pour gérer la
situation
sauver entre guillemets par la disparité
qui existe encore entre les départements
effectivement oliveira en a parlé de ces
transferts des dizaines voire une
centaine de patients transférés c'est
une solution viable à court terme
seulement
c'est probablement même single shot on
peut faire une fois ce genre de choses
mais on ne peut pas tous les jours
entreprendre de m
des dizaines de patients dans des trains
pour aller vers la province d'abord
parce que les capacités d'accueil en
provence vont rapidement être saturé et
puis ensuite parce que la logistique à
mettre en place pour transférer ces
patients est extrêmement lourde vous
montrer des images et maintenant tout le
monde à l'habitude de voir des images de
réanimation et chaque fois qu'on voit
ces images de réanimation il ya une deux
trois personnes autour du patient et on
comprend bien que le transfert doit se
faire avec les mêmes règles de sécurité
que la réanimation donc avec beaucoup de
personnel et beaucoup d'encadrement
d'autant plus que fait s'enchaîner au
cours de ces transferts des périodes à
risque chaque fois qu'un patient de
réanimation est passé de son lit à un
brancard puis du brancard à une
ambulance puis de l'ambulance à l'avion
ou aux trains etc
on prend un risque majeur chaque fois
parce qu'on peut accrocher un fils on
peut accrocher un tuyau et que la vie de
ces patients est suspendu à ses fils et
à ses tuyaux donc c'est très complexe
d'un point de vue logistique et c'est
périlleux exigeants en ressources
humaines
donc c'est pas si simple que ça
d'imaginer qu'on va transférer des
dizaines et j'ai du mal à croire qu'on
puisse envisager de transférer des
centaines de patients alors en cause
peut être notamment de ce fut très tendu
les variants là encore pas très
encourageant olivier ferrand n'a pas
caché son inquiétude en disant qu'ils
étaient plus contagieux et plus
dangereuse c'est votre avis professeurs
aussi vous le constater sur le terrain
alors de toute façon il n'y avait aucun
doute sur le fait que à court terme dès
son apparition le vario anglais serait
amené à remplacer totalement le variant
internationale qui c'est comme ça la vie
la vie des la vie des virus le plus
virulent prend la place prend la place
des autres on était sûr qu'il était plus
contagieux raison pour laquelle il
devient prédominant et malheureusement
des études récentes laissent à penser
qu'ils pourraient aussi être associée à
une plus forte mortalité donc les deux
éléments qui caractérisent un virus et
d'une part sa contagiosité
d'autre part sa mortalité et en a
malheureusement l'impression avec ce
virus qu'on perde sur les deux registres
qui sont les profils des personnes
admises en réanimation vers l'est de
mortalité est ce qu'il y à davantage de
jeunes qui sont touchés désormais à la
fois peut-être parce que les plus vieux
se font vacciner parce que peut-être que
ce variant attaque davantage les
personnes plus jeunes alors vous avez
raison il ya deux évolutions la première
c'est que finalement on arrive
aujourd'hui à une surcharge des services
de réanimation avec une surcharge à un
peu moindre des services d'urgence les
patients sont gérés en amont de
l'hôpital plus longtemps on a même des
patients qui ont l'oxygène à la maison
la plupart des passions les moyens de
surveiller d'oxygène dans le sang à la
maison dès qu'ils sont malades et en
fait on a intervient nous pour les
transférer à l'hôpital à la limite quand
vraiment c'est plus possible de les
maintenir à domicile et ce qui fait que
le taux de patients arrivant à l'hôpital
qui a besoin de la réanimation est un
taux qui est plus élevé alors
effectivement on a plutôt maintenant
tendance à avoir moins de patients âgés
et très âgées d'abord parce qu'ils ont
été vaccinées ensuite parce que les plus
fragiles ont déjà pu la maladie dans des
bacs précédente
mais par contre et c'est important de le
savoir
il ya de nombreux patients plus jeunes
qui sont hospitalisés qu'ils soient
hospitalisés en réanimation avec les
formes graves et effectivement la
plupart du temps on retrouve des
facteurs favorisants qui sont maintenant
bien connus comme en particulier
l'obésité chez ces patients merci
beaucoup en tout cas à frédéric
lapostolle nous avoir accordé ces
quelques minutes dans votre emploi du
temps chargé on imagine merci à vous et
c'est dans ce contexte tendu par la
pandémie que les employés de sanofi
continue à manifester plusieurs mois
après l'annoncé de suppressions de
postes dans la branche recherche et
développement les syndicats tentent de
prendre les choses en main ils ont été
reçus aujourd'hui par des conseillers
bruno le maire un sujet de mes diester
fissures des images d'aujourd'hui demory
ce jeudi plusieurs dizaines de salariés
du groupe sanofi rassemblés devant le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
objectif de cette mobilisation protester
contre les suppressions d'emplois
annoncées par la direction
à l'échelle de l'europe ce sont mille
700 emplois qui sont menacés mille en
france dont 400 dans le département
recherche et développement des employés
qui regrette la financiarisation du
secteur avec des objectifs économiques
qui passeraient avant ceux liés à la
santé
ils veulent donc se faire entendre
auprès du gouvernement alors en termes
de formes de financiarisation on est au
delà de la forme maintenant un peu ce
que sanofi revendique carrément son
appartenance à la finance puisqu'il eux
ils se gargarisent donc de 26 ans
d'augmentation du dividende
on arrive l'année dernière 4 milliards
de donner aux actionnaires cette année
rebelote 4 milliards et en même temps en
pleine pandémie et ben sanou fils a le
culot de vouloir licencier de dégraisser
donc entre autres sa recherche et son
développement
en attendant sanofi a annoncé des
retards de livraison de son vaccin
contre le coc vite 19
certains employés font directement le
lien entre la réduction des effectifs et
une recherche moins efficace des
salariés en colère soutenu par la gauche
notamment la france insoumise
l'échec sur le vaccin est l'espèce de
traduction de chat quand on divise par
deux surnoms de chercheurs en disant
quand on supprime tous les ans des
centres de recherche mais ça va encore
se produire cet automne strasbourg qui
perdent 400 chercheurs qui fait qu'ils
partent évidemment peut pas attendre
qu'on crée ans un tel chaos dans la
rolls cherche ça aboutisse à obtenir un
vaccin assez rapidement certains
syndicats ont été reçus par des
conseillers du ministre de l'économie à
la sortie de cette réunion un constat
pessimiste impossibilité d'agir pour les
autorités car sanofi est une entreprise
privée
face à cette forme de fatalisme du
gouvernement les contestataires ont
néanmoins décidé de poursuivre leur
journée de mobilisation ce groupe de
salariés venus de montpellier s'est
rendu ce jeudi après-midi sus devant le
siège de sanofi après des jets d'oeuf et
de farine ils ont posé des autocollants
sur l'enceinte ça avant l'audition
c'est des faux billets à l'effigié du
patron du géant pharmaceutique
depuis 2009 on vit des plans sociaux à
tire larigot à la place dupuis de 80 des
projets de recherche en france on avait
au centre de recherche on est à trois
ans ce qui explique aussi le premier
contact demain parce qu'encore une fois
on va perdre des postes et en plus comme
moi sanofi quand même première
entreprise française du médicament
même pas foutu de trouver un vaccin
moyens d'action qu'on a trouvé c'est
toucher leur image et en fin de compte
on s'est rendu compte que sanofi ce
qu'il déteste le plus c'est qu'on touche
à son image de marque
donc dès qu'on a des nouveaux patrons et
tous les trois-quatre ans ça change
dès qu'on a des nouveaux patrons ont
refait des billets à leurs effigies de
la monnaie qu'on appelle la monnaie sano
fric qui représente exactement la
marchandisation du médicament qui sont
en train de faire dans notre société
face à la multiplication des plans
sociaux dans l'entreprise les employés
promettent de continuer à se battre
d'autres actions sont prévues à l'avenir
notamment sur le site de strasbourg
menacée de fermeture emmanuel macron va
bien commémorer le bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon le 5 mai prochain
l'empereur est une figure majeure de
notre histoire a précisé hier le
porte-parole gabriela talent si cette
commémoration d'une figure majeure de
l'histoire par ailleurs personnalité
préférée des français une évidence pour
certains cet événement ne fait pas
l'unanimité pour autant d'un côté il ya
le vainqueur d'austerlitz
l'homme qui a pacifié la france le
créateur du code civil
mais de l'autre il ya aussi celui qui a
rétabli l'esclavagé la figure historique
qui fascine et hitler et à la lumière
d'un regard contemporain
napoléon a contre lui les
anticolonialistes les antimilitaristes
ou bien encore les féministes alors
faut-il commémorer ce bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon qu'elle napoléon
célébrer le débats restent animés autour
du petit caporal c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre non ça vous avec
christian bourdeilles président du
souvenir napoléonien danièle obono
députés elle est fille de paris bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france évidemment il y
aura une commémoration par le président
de la république 1 ce sont les paroles
de gabriella talent à l'issue du conseil
des ministres
évidemment pas si évident pour vous
peut-être danièle obono écoutez c'est un
choix politique de fait emmanuel macron
habits sens même de ce pouvoir qui
célèbre mur autoritaire et actionnaire
est choisi par exemple de ne pas
célébrer le cinquantenaire de la côte et
on voit bien que dans ce choix
il ya un choix politique au delà de la
figure historique il par ailleurs est
enseignée est connu et donc n'a pas en
soi besoin de plus de notoriété qu'elle
en a déjà et ce n'est certainement pas
emmanuel macron d'affaires d'écrire
napoléon est ce qu'il a pu accomplir en
termes historiques
donc je crois que le débat qui existe
est légitime parce que encore une fois
c'est pourquoi on choisit cette figure à
ce moment là et pourquoi politiquement
ça pose problème parce que il y a de mon
point de vue dans cet héritage
énormément de choses problématique
christian bourdaillet choix politiques
pour danièle obono on partageait ce
diagnostic
écoutez je crois que c'est pas un choix
politique enfin moi je suis pas à la
place du président de la république ce
qui est clair c'est que cette année en
2021 nous avons le 5 mai 2021 qui
correspond donc au bicentenaire de la
mort de napoléon 1er et qui est une
grande figure de notre histoire
donc il n'y a pas
à contester ou pas contester c'est une
réalité et moi je suis président du
souvenir napoléonien
je suis à la tête d'une association qui
existe depuis 1937 qui n'est pas
complètement nouveau et parce que
napoléon occupe une place importante
dans notre histoire et qu il a apporté
beaucoup de choses
simplement il a apporté le code civil
qui était à l'époque et encore
aujourd'hui c'est notre manière de vivre
ensemble et à l'époque vous pouvez pas
imaginer ce que ça a été donc
d'introduire le code civil c'est à dire
que on avait plus besoin de passer
devant donc un religieux en l'occurrence
un curé et quand on n'était pas de
région catholique son mariage n'existait
pas et là avec le code civil
nous avons une avancée considérable ce
que les révolutionnaires ne vais pas
réussi à faire napoléon d'abord premier
consul de la république donc a réussi à
le faire et c'est une ses plus grandes
réussites
s'ils voulaient napoléon c'est l'homme
des réformes et pas des réformes
simplement donc en mots en discours il
les a réalisés et moi je considère que
napoléon 1er consul d'abord de la
république plus empereur des français
est celui qui a sauvé la révolution donc
sans napoléon on risquait fortement
d'avoir un établissement de la monarchie
et les fondamentaux donc de la
révolution n'ont eux pas été remise en
cause
c'est ça qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire et il faut voir les
dernières années de la période dite
révolutionnaire où les coups d'état se
sont multipliées puisque quand on
n'était pas content du résultat des
élections
eh bien on en voyait donc en prison un
slam d'hommes politiques donc napoléon à
stabiliser et toutes nos grandes
institutions aujourd'hui on lui doit
c'est tout c'est une réalité alors elle
distribue sa part à l'utiliser ou pas
c'est autre chose
bon on va on va continuer ce débat
danièle obono cv vous êtes d'accord
quand même avec une partie du diagnostic
de christian bourdeilles c'est l'homme
des institutions c'est l'homme du code
civil ce que aujourd'hui vous jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain si j'ose
employer cette expression un peu
familière à mais pas du tout y compris
moi même j'ai été à une époque très
intéressé par cette histoire j'ai lu
tous les grandes les grands romans de
l'épopée napoléonienne donc encore une
fois il ne s'agit pas de rejeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain c'est un fait ça a
été un moment de l'histoire important
mais on peut avoir des honda et il
existe y compris en terme de débats
historiques d d d d arguments pour dire
par exemple moi je ne crois pas que
napoléon et continuer la révolution je
pense qu'il y a mis un terme et qui fait
partie de ceux qui ont réussi des coups
d'état et l'installation de l' empire
après la révolution c'est c'est un coup
d'état napoléonien chi chi chi
l'institut il a également alors vous
parliez du code civil mais dans un code
civil qui institue la ferrure isation
des femmes par exemple
donc c'est un code civil patriarcale et
qui n'est pas absolument progressistes
c'est aussi celui qui a rétabli
l'esclavagé contre la révolution
notamment haïtienne une révolution par
ailleurs dont on parle peu qu'on
enseigne peu en france alors que ça fait
partie de notre histoire nationale c'est
quand même cette première révolution qui
s'inspire d'ailleurs de la révolution
française qui établit au bout d'une très
longue guerre et très et très et très
meurtrière et très est très cher parce
que haïti va le payer jusqu'à jusqu'à
très longtemps 7 sept
cette épopée napoléonienne dans les
caraïbes mais on n'en parle quasiment
jamais alors alors danièle obono parce
qu'un juge jusqu'aux membres du
gouvernement on en parle je vous propose
d'écouter des web et moreno un ministre
de l'égalité et de la diversité qui met
de l'eau à votre moulin écouter la
napoléon était l'un des plus grands
misogynes que j'ai jamais lu
il a rétabli l'esclavagé et en même
temps c'est un grand homme de l'histoire
française donc je passe je ne sais pas
bon elle fait du dans le même temps un
christian bordin en même temps elle est
au gouvernement christian ben day c'est
vrai que ça revient souvent à la
misogynie l'esclavagisme qu'est ce que
vous répondez
écoutez moi je suis pas là pour dire que
napoléon a fait que des choses
extraordinaires
moi je suis donc encore une fois
président d'une société historique qui
s'appelle le souvenir napoléonien
nous nous faisons de l'histoire il ya
des aspects positifs pour moi les
aspects positifs l'emportent très
largement encore une fois je vais pas
vous faire la liste de tout ce qu'il a
réalisé
il ya des aspects négatifs bien
évidemment et j'irai heureusement si je
disais pas ça ce qu'on ne ferait pas de
l'histoire ou s'il fallait faire aussi
un débat sur la république et la
troisième république où on pourrait vous
dire aussi la 3ème république c'est la
colonisation c'est jules ferry donc en
âme et celle affaire dreyfus
imaginez une affaire dreyfus sous le
second empire ça serait extraordinaire
ça serait de bonnes occasions mais
malheureusement la sphère dreyfus sas
est passé sous la république la
troisième république donc je crois que
tout régime à ces aspects positifs à ces
aspects négatifs pour revenir à cet
épisode donc de haïti il faut voir qu'il
ya eu des expéditions donc pour rétablir
l'ordre
avant napoléon on dirait que napoléon a
tout fait ce qui n'est pas vrai
j'aurais simplement aussi précisé que
napoléon n'a pas rétabli l'esclavagé
il l'a maintenu dans les colonies qui
avait été prise par donc la présence
britannique
d'autre part la polio en 1915 c'est
l'homme qui met fin donc au trafic
voilà donc napoléon voulait pas raciste
de base il était comme dans
malheureusement comme beaucoup d'autres
à son époque un et même encore avant
puisque certains disent que voltaire
était aussi donc un esclavagiste etc etc
on pourrait élargir ce vaste débat à
d'autres
d'autres périodes historiques parce que
l' esclavage à une très longue histoire
malheureusement c'est pas un aplomb qui
l'a inventé l' esclavage dans les pays
du moyen-orient
ça existe depuis de nombreux siècles et
personne n'en parle beaucoup en ce
moment
donc moi je veux bien que napoléon
effectivement a commis des erreurs je
effectivement c'est une erreur je vais
pas dire le contraire
moi encore une fois je ne suis pas un
homme politique je fais de l'histoire et
je suis là pour rappeler que encore une
fois le premier empire est aussi le
second empire
ce sont des pages historique fondamental
de l'histoire de france
qu'on en discute bien évidemment moi je
suis pas contre qu'on en débatte bien au
contraire
moi je suis très heureux que ça crée
donc un débat faisons de l'histoire et
faisons de l'histoire aussi autour de la
république qui a eu beaucoup de mal
aussi à accorder le droit de vote aux
aux femmes puisque parlons-en aussi la
fallu attendre le général de gaulle qui
a priori n'est pas un homme de gauche
ah c'est le général de gaulle c'est pas
le front populaire c'est le général de
gaulle par son ordonnance de 1945 à
alger qui donne enfin le droit de vote
aux femmes
donc voilà donc sortons des a priori
politique droite gauche ou pas je
pourrais aussi vous dire que lorsqu'on
appelle le coup d'état du 2 décembre
1851 sa rétabli le suffrage universel
que la république donc avait restreint
donc là aussi c'est pas noir ou blanc
dany faisons de l'histoire moi je suis
très heureux quand on fait l'histoire
non c'est l'occasion en tout cas danièle
obono le fait que napoléon ça soit la
figure l'une des figures historiques
préférée des français devant le général
de gaulle ça ça vous heurte qu'est ce
que ça dit selon vous de la société
française aujourd'hui
ben non je voulais dis moi même j'ai été
très passionné par cette histoire et
j'ai fait de l'histoire à l'université
justement parce que ce sont des moments
extrêmement intéressant donc je ne sais
pas une question de heurter et
effectivement je pense qu'il ya le débat
historique et les différentes lectures
qu'on peut avoir de la révolution de l'
empire et des critiques que l'on peut
faire ça c'est une chose et je ne vais
pas absolument pas en cause le travail
des institutions qui font de l'histoire
et qui choisit ce telle ou telle période
le débat qui existe il est politique
parce que effectivement tous les
gouvernements n'ont pas célébré napoléon
sa naissance a man who ou ses victoires
militaires
de la même manière et c'est le choix qui
est fait alors oui qu'il soit populaire
comme beaucoup de figures historiques la
question c'est aussi pourquoi est ce que
certaines figures sont célébrés est
connu et transmises dans l'enseignement
et pourquoi d'autres sons sont
un visibiliser je vous parlais d'haïti
je pourrais vous parler
je reviens sur le sens le cent
cinquantenaire de la commune qui est
aussi parce qu'il fait partie aussi de
cette grande histoire du 19ème et des
révolutions et qui a et qui a été
écrasée dans le sang et dans et dans une
répression très forte
c'est aujourd'hui un événement une
partie de l'histoire mais il n'ya pas
que célébration
t'as du gouvernement à ce moment là et
je pense qu'aussi il écoute les les
figures de la commune était plus connue
est plus célébrées mais peut-être que ça
ferait partie des figures par exemple
louise michel à sa place de mon point de
vue au panthéon de l'histoire de france
et pourtant on entend peu parler donc
encore une fois je crois que notre
histoire c'est celle de toutes les
histoires avec des contradictions et on
en débat la question et moi ce qui
m'interpelle ce n'est pas que les
français et françaises trouvent cette
figure très inspirante c'est le choix
politique et idéologique parce que ça
renvoie à un certain nombre de valeurs
qu'est-ce qui est célébrée et je crois
que ça dit beaucoup plus en fait de la
macro ni aujourd'hui de faire ce choix
là que samedi de la société de son
histoire et c'est ça qui m'interpelle et
c'est ça que que je que je critique dans
le choix aujourd'hui mais bon merci en
tout cas à tous les deux on arrive déjà
bien heureusement la fin de ce débat
qu'on reprendra certainement autour du 5
mai merci à vous deux christian
bourdeilles et danièle obono en tout cas
on a compris le message des deux merci à
vous restez avec nous nous parlerons
dans quelques instants avec l'économiste
jacques sapir des taux d'intérêt qui
remonte sur les marchés des centrales un
renchérissement du crédit
et puis nous irons centrafrique où le
deuxième tour des élections législatives
doivent avoir lieu ce dimanche dans un
contexte de guerre civile
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation de
la gestion de l'épidémie on voit bien qu
un système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements pas masquer dans
un premier temps pas de test dans un
second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins on a senti que
vous étiez nerveux et agacé à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif
quant à au déploiement de la vaccination
et je constate c'est que l'on est le 36e
pays en matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
l'un va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara fuyant la france
comme l'europe a été absente de
l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume du
maroc
les algériens évidemment mécontents
considère la décision américaine comme
une ingérence dans un problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va de suicide et
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et dans l'hymne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu
les big for books les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce que quelqu'un s'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux à dole à
des entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez et si
emprunter devenait plus cher depuis peu
et taux d'intérêt remonte sur les
marchés ce qui laisse craindre un
renchérissement du crédit est partie des
états unis le phénomène commence à
gagner l'europe alors va-t-on vers une
fin de ce qu'on appelle l'argent gratuit
ou presque dans quelle mesure cette
retombée des taux est elle un danger
pour les entreprises et des ménages les
plus endettés c'est d'objets de l'édito
échos ce soir bonsoir jacques sapir
bonsoir c'est fanny jacques cette hausse
dont des taux d'intérêt est elle une
véritable menace
alors oui c'est potentiellement une
menace parce que on va voir que les taux
d'endettement que ce soit les taux
d'endettement des ménages ou des
entreprises sont très élevés et
effectivement ça serait une catastrophe
si les taux remonter brutalement
maintenant il faut dire que ce n'est pas
encore le cas sauf aux états unis où on
assiste depuis cet été à une remontée
constante des taux on voit que pour
l'instant cette remontée des taux est
très modérée
néanmoins il y a clairement un problème
sous jacent là qui est présent alors
dans quelle mesure jacques l'endettement
est il un problème pour les ménages mais
aussi pour les entreprises évidemment
alors pour les ménages si vous voulez
c'est un problème tout à fait évident
les ménages américains les ménages
britanniques y sont parmi les plus
endettés aurait beaucoup de mal à
supporter une forte remontée des taux
mais même le cas des ménages français
regardez les ménages français ont vu
leur taux d'endettement augmenté de 60 à
65% en l'équivalent de quatre trimestres
donc oui ça peut être potentiellement un
énorme problème
et puis il n'ya pas que les ménages il
ya aussi toute la question de
l'endettement des entreprises
là pour la france c'est un problème
vraiment très important parce que en ce
qui concerne l'endettement des
entreprises
on voit que la france elle se situe
pratiquement au niveau du japon ou au
niveau de l'espagne donc des pays qui
sont où les entreprises sont très
endettés et là aussi si les taux
augmentent et ça pourrait être une
catastrophe pour l'économie française et
pour les états jacques ne sont ils pas
eux aussi très endetté oui naturellement
naturellement les états se sont tous
très endettés alors sans même parler du
cas du japon qui est endetté à
l'équivalent de 250 % de son pib
on a aussi le problème des états qui
sont à plus de 100 % de dette par
rapport à leur pib
maintenant il faut dire une chose c'est
que si les états ont pu justement
s'endetter de telle manière
c'est bien parce que l'argent a été
quasiment gratuit c'est le même problème
d'ailleurs pour par exemple les
entreprises ou pour les ménages outre la
question du revenu des ménages
donc on voit bien ici que c'est en
raison de ces taux très faibles que les
états ont pratiquement tous décidé de
laisser filer la dette et jeanne
justement quelle est l'ampleur de cette
de cette hausse des taux dont on parle
alors pour ce qui est des états unis
on voit que c'est un plan avait quand
même pas négligeable puisqu'on est
revenue pratiquement au niveau où on
était avant la crise sanitaire
d'ailleurs il ya un point qui était tout
à fait intéressant c'est que sur cette
courbe alors c'est peut-être pas très
visible à l'écran mais en fait les taux
remontent ce taux à 10 ans remonte
depuis la fin du mois de juillet 2020
donc là oui il ya un problème et comme
je vous le disais les to sont maintenant
pratiquement au niveau où il était au
début de 2020 donc on a bien le
sentiment là que l'économie américaine
en tous les cas pour ce qui concerne sa
sphère financière eh bien elle semble
être revenu
à la situation d'avant la crise
financière et est ce donc jacques la
même chose dans la zone euro oui là
aussi on voit que les taux sont en train
de remonter mais alors il remonte
d'abord beaucoup moins les les tours de
la zone euro sont encore majoritairement
négatifs
ce n'est pas le cas aux états unis il
remonte depuis seulement le mois de
décembre dernier
pas depuis le mois de juillet donc on
voit que c'est un phénomène qui est
nettement moins important mais néanmoins
il est très impressionnant de voir que
tous les taux remontent
qu'il s'agisse du taux à 10 ans du taux
à 5 ans du taux à un an donc tous les
tourments et alors quand on parle des
taux européens
on parle aussi évidemment des taux
français voilà il s'affiche et alors
pour ce qui de la france n'at il ya
peut-être une petite différence avec la
moyenne des taux européens en france
bien sûr on voit sur les courbes
le point d'inflexion et on voit que la
courbe des taux à 10 ans commence à
remonter mais ça reste encore beaucoup
plus faible que dans la moyenne en
europe
évidemment beaucoup plus faible qu'aux
états unis et donc de ce point de vue là
on peut penser que nous sommes
relativement protégé alors jacques est
ce à dire qu'on est tranquille
finalement pour le moment en france
alors à court terme
oui c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
évident et il faut comprendre une chose
c'est que une hausse des taux serait
tellement catastrophiques pour
l'économie que ce soit pour l'état pour
les entreprises voire pour les ménages
que la banque centrale européenne fera
tout pour maintenir des taux très
faibles
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il y avait une
réunion à la banque centrale européenne
et la banque centrale européenne a
décidé d'augmenter au contraire ses
rachats d'obligations aux banques ce qui
est une méthode en réalité pour re faire
baisser les taux mais mais il faut bien
voir que en dépit de ce genre de
politique malgré tout il y à un
mouvement de pression à la hausse des
taux ce qui fait que s'il n'y a pas de
risque dans l'immédiat
on ne peut pas exclure des problèmes à
plus long
terme un an un an et demi alors je vous
repose donc la question faut-il quand
même s'inquiéter de ce mouvement de
hausse des taux pour les mois et les
années qui viennent
vous avez tout à fait raison de poser de
problème dans ces termes
s'il n'y a pas de problème dans
l'immédiat
oui bien entendu une hausse des taux
pourrait être catastrophique dans l'état
actuel de nos économies après il faut
voir un autre problème c'est que on est
en présence d'un mouvement qui existe à
la fois aux états unis mais aussi en
europe
on l'a vu simplement ce qui est
différent aujourd'hui c'est que les
états unis ont pris des avances et
pourquoi ont-ils pris de l'avancé
et bien parce que l'économie américaine
se redresse beaucoup plus rapidement que
l'économie de la zone euro ou que
l'économie de l'union européenne
d'une certaine manière et ça sera ma
troisième observation et bien le retard
que nous avons pris dans ce mouvement de
hausse des taux et bien ce retard il
traduit aussi un retard économique que
nous sommes en train de prendre par
rapport aux états unis et donc il n'est
pas non plus une si bonne nouvelle que
cela maintenant il faut dire que les
banques centrales
on peut le penser vont toujours veillé
au grain mais jacques on surveillera c&o
comme le lait sur le feu merci à vous et
à la semaine prochaine
dans le reste de l'actualité le japon
commémore avec émotion la triple
catastrophe du 11 mars 2011 une minute
de silence a été observée dans tout le
pays à 14h46 c'est à cette heure précise
dix ans plutôt que le pays a été frappé
par l'un des plus violent séisme jamais
enregistré dans le monde
un tremblement de terre qui a déclenché
un tsunami meurtriers suivis de
l'accident nucléaire à la centrale de
fukushima la triple catastrophe a fait
près de 18000 1 500 morts ou disparus
principalement du fait du tsunami
retour sur ce drame avec solène gaudin
un séisme sous-marin de magnitude 9
puis une vague de 23 mètres de haut qui
s'écrase sur la côte nord-est du japon
emportant tout sur son passage
le bilan humain est lourd près de 20000
morts et 2500 disparu les villes sont
dévastés 165 mille habitants sont
déplacés au tsunami succès d'un accident
nucléaire qui donnera son nom à
l'événement
la catastrophe de fukushima à 12
kilomètres de la ville une centrale
nucléaire est inondée par la vague
provoquant une fusion partielle des
coeurs des réacteurs
s'ensuit une explosion libérant des
substances radioactives dans
l'atmosphère laissant craindre une
intoxication des populations des terres
et des eaux commence alors une vaste
opération de décontamination les caméras
du monde entier sont braqués sur les 50
de fukushima ses employés de la centrale
restait sur place malgré l'exposition
aux radiations
dix ans plus tard les travaux de
nettoyage se poursuivent
des montagnes de terres radioactives ont
été stockés près de fukushima à titre
provisoire mais au moins jusqu'en 2045
le temps de trouver une structure pour
les isoler à ce jour 15 % de la zone à
décontaminer ont été nettoyés le
démantèlement de la centrale pourrait
lui prendre encore 30 à 40 ans les
anti-nucléaires japonais manifestent
contre la lenteur et l'opacité des
opérations notamment à l' approche des
jeux olympiques de tokyo près
vu cet été je veux que la centrale
touchés par la crise soient mises hors
service plus rapidement mais on ne sait
pas quand elle le sera enfin j'ai
vraiment peur que plusieurs réacteurs
soient encore exploités je veux que les
réacteurs endommagés soit pris en charge
le plus rapidement possible nous les
japonais ne savons toujours pas comment
se fait le déplacement
je suis très déçu je ne pense pas du
tout que les habitants de fukushima
croient que les jeux olympiques aideront
à la reconstruction le gouvernement nous
impose cette idée en disant que ce
seront les jeux olympiques de la
reconstruction et que la centrale
nucléaire de fukushima est sous contrôle
ce n'est pas vrai je crains que le site
n'explose si une catastrophe se produit
à nouveau si les craintes pour la santé
publique demeure quant aux conséquences
de l'explosion de la centrale nucléaire
un rapport scientifique sur ses
répercussions sur la population et
l'environnement publié ce mercredi par
le comité scientifique des nations unies
pour l'étude des effets des rayonnements
ionisants conclu en revanche à l'absence
de suite directe
selon cette étude les rejets radioactifs
emportée par le vent n'aurait pas touché
terre sur près de 25 mille salariés de
la centrale
seuls six auraient reçu une dose de
radioactivité supérieurs à 250
millisieverts tu doses équivalentes à
celles subies par les pompiers mobilisés
autour de la centrale de tchernobyl en
ukraine
les habitants eux auraient été soumis à
des doses plus faibles
toujours selon ce rapport ce drame a
bien eu des retombées environnementales
causées par les gigantesques opérations
de décontamination
mais en centrafrique à quelques jours du
second tour des élections législatives
le doute plane quant à l'implication des
rebelles religieux et habitants se
mobilisent pour ramener un message de
paix dans tout le pays tous souhaitent
éviter une nouvelle guerre civile et
confessionnelles entre les différentes
communautés centrafricaine pas comme
pendant 10 et cyrielle boe
rodez abîmé véhicules embourbés un
simple trajet qui se transforme en un
véritable périple pour le cardinal
centrafricain dieudonné à palanga près
de 100 kilomètres seulement séparent la
piste de birao et la ville de ouandda
djallé située dans le nord du pays
pourtant le cardinal et son équipe ont
mis plus de quatre heures pour parcourir
cette distance
c'est de cette partie du territoire que
proviennent la majorité des groupes
rebelles présents centrafrique depuis
les décennies soit 6 à quoi dans le soir
où ces petites ben ali un drame s'était
déjà produit ici tous les villages
autour de nous ont déjà subi la guerre
merci aux autorités qui ont envoyé des
forces à luanda pour protéger
aujourd'hui la population
il n'y a plus de problème les habitants
et les forces entendent bien ici on n'a
déjà pas d'eau potable pas d'hôpital
quand un enfant est malade à où honda il
faut faire plusieurs kilomètres
ou bien tu le perds en route en plus de
ça la guerre encore on demande plutôt de
l'aide pour le développement de notre
région
nous sommes aussi des humains
depuis quelques semaines l'armée
centrafricaine appuyé par la russie et
le rwanda avance dans le pays pour
libérer les zones occupées par les
rebelles
ces derniers menacent de prendre le
pouvoir et était même arrivé jusqu'aux
portes de la capitale centrafricaine
bangui en janvier dernier dans leur
repli les groupes armés ont prévu de
converger vers la région du nord à
majorité musulmane qui a souvent été en
proie aux violences
je viens tout le temps à l'église
catholique ici mes frères prêtres aussi
viennent régulièrement chez moi à la
mosquée on discute pour voir quoi faire
pour maintenir la paix pour le moment ce
sont les groupes armés le gouvernement
qui doivent voir comment nous ramener
cette paix s'il décide de s'entendre
cette paix va revenir une paix que
défend également l'archevêque de bangui
dieudonné à palanga
ce dernier s'est rendu dans cette région
menacée de centrafrique afin de parer
d'éventuels conflits entre les
communautés chrétienne et musulmane
cette visite est en fait aussi une
présentation
sociopolitique une source d
en fait signer un accord j'ai rencontré
mais un réseau 3g mais je réalise les
clowns désistement ses forces et
faiblesses autour de cet apport pour
encourager les uns et les autres à
sortir de cette situation le pays si sa
visite dans la région a été brève le
cardinal a tenu à rappeler la dimension
politique de cette dernière alors que le
second tour des législatives
centrafricaines doit se dérouler ce
dimanche dans un climat incertain
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
aristide briand robot haas ex candidat à
la présidentielle 2020 à hauteur de agir
pour ce vais sauver la république
centrafricaine aux éditions l'harmattan
bonsoir aristide-briand robot à ce
deuxième tour des législatives qui
s'approche à grands pas dans un contexte
tendu on imagine que l'inquiétude est
palpable sur place oui je vous remercie
de m'avoir donné la femme c'est vrai que
nous sommes ont créé ce qui n'est pas
nouvelle c'est que je pense que le
climat de la 2 dans deux documents de
deuxième tour sera plus ou moins légales
comme un climat je prenais tout mais
naturellement d'essence elles touchaient
ou sécurisés c2pay nations de se
précipiter à l'encré 2006 qu'un de
sécurisation des personnes et des biens
est pas difficile
les candidats étaient maculés d'années
j'ai vu m'a choisi aujourd'hui clermont
l'a entendu un dans ce sujet les
populations craignent une guerre
confessionnelle qui aggraverait encore
plus la situation déjà difficile de la
centrafrique est ce que clairement
aujourd'hui selon vous on peut l'éviter
cette guerre je pense qu'il y aura pas
de guerre aujourd'hui nous avons une
crise sociopolitique un coup d'état car
maintenant qu'il est à chaque fois on
nous paraît sortir ses impressions de
guerre contre ce prix oui c'est la
gestion de la crise entraîne ces gens de
peu de buts de guerre professionnel vous
avez bien vu que aujourd'hui des
syndicats il n'est pas la cas qu'ils
étaient des ennemis d'hier soit disant
la guerre est un logique de la guerre en
question les amener à 28 août et 5e
risque de huitième ou des douze imams et
aujourd'hui sens je pense que raison ou
l'a4 long du bloc nous paraît 2 est de
2,2 de guerre on tait soit on est prêt
nous avons comme on appelle ça un coup
d'état en ces stations nous avons de
land art mais nous avons un conflit en
république centrafricaine kacou aux
rafles de tarbes qui pousse à bouger et
sauget
nous avons aussi des étrangers et qui
sont venus par exemple y tient et qui
cita et ce après oslo plus de battante
et la rca développe une culture de
guerre tout le commando de tous genres
anciaux député de saint tin tuc elle est
tantôt peiné pour exploiter l'or le
diamant piller les ressources elle est
par contre se capitaliser la coopération
il trouve toujours un moyen de créer des
situations de déstabilisation au point
de ne pas accepter l'autorité touche et
ça permet de parier locales et vue de
2de bac est halal et de continuer à pied
est donc cette crise je pense que
paraisse de la compression ce n'est pas
ou moins là là là là l'hôtel nous avons
rue comme en appel à une crise qui n'a
jamais ou alors la solution la poste ou
les omissions nascar
tu prends celle du pauvre apporter comme
on appelle ça poser de vraies questions
et met le doigt sur le monde à côté la
solution que la et donc au moins nous
avons eu ce qui est une crise
sociopolitique elle due par exemple à la
menthe minute par partage des richesses
et c'était là et qui dit bhl sociaux et
socioculturels
c'était la honte et la solution à ce
niveau on a vu que la russie étaient sur
place le rwanda aussi mais aucun pays
dit occidental pour quelles raisons
selon vous moi je pense que la personne
à qui la charrue résolution tout s'est
étonnée c'est d'abord au sénat dans le
cadre des nations-unies tous les rythmes
ans accuse l'occident ou grand complet
je trouve aussi du nord et il aa dans le
cadre de thé ou parmi les soldats et les
qui devra aussi les accompagner en fait
ce qui me touche ça parce que je suis
aussi tous de constater que cette course
internationale les nations qui proposé
par toutes les grandes puissances et
russie l'union européenne
il exige qu'ils n'arrivent pas à nous
apporter de la percussion et oui on a
obligé de se traiter avec le force
toulouse loin d'être passés si des
autorités on s'attend du champ selon
l'onu la centrafrique est le deuxième
pays de l'eu moins développés du monde
selon vous le nouveau président faustin
archange
touadéra peut-il faire évoluer les
choses
le réseau social à france 3 0 avait déjà
bien commencé quand il appelle la
décision n'était pas allé pour intégrer
les vous a ramené dans le google m'a
jeté le grenier à l'abri on sert le mât
ou quoi parce que c'était ce qu'ils
valent mais quand il avait commencé par
céder à la négociation la cote à
excellent à cet accord qui a en quelque
sorte tu trouves pas toute la terre et
ses 7 à quoi qu'il sait 16 cet accord
qui après que aujourd'hui les groupes
armés se sont démultipliés nous avons vu
par exemple de tustin boulot par né et
où la ceinture de ces accords on a dû
sélectionner 14e rebours ou intégrer le
gouvernement et les autres se sentaient
lésés et nous avons comme l'impression
que la mort a renversé la rita
aujourd'hui tu ne peut pas exister en
tant qu'intellectuel et prétendre à des
postes de responsabilité c'est difficile
mais par contre c'est facile avec cet
apport n'est que tu peux prendre des
arts et en contrepartie nez bouché des
postures responsabilité et ce qui est
encore dangereux donc ces accords c'est
quoi vous avez des gens qui n'ont jamais
été à l'époque louis dutech il sait
jamais quoi très informés qu'ils ont
sauvé au toit et des claques et généreux
qui témoin ou gouvernement pourrait
connaître leur a dit ça c'est pour moi
c'est de point de non retour de ces deux
poids des possibilités et alors nous
avons eu une unité bons appels à l'unité
blixen eux n'y sont pas entraînés fort
sur le mec et le gouvernement
cela en plus belle mais elle va
permettre grâce à cela leur a permis
talent de beaucoup de sources des
techniques est vital de se douter des
tarifs
le short jours dont celle de british
n'ayant pas l'habitude merci en tout cas
reste merci pardonner monde a compris le
message on arrive même mais
malheureusement à la fin de cette
interview bercy aristide-briand rebboah
ça d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france pour évoquer la situation de
la centrafrique merci à bout et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi prochain pour un complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
pierre pissavy yvernault
[Musique]
freiner le réchauffement climatique tout
en stimulant la croissance voici
grossièrement la finalité de ce que l'on
appelle communément la relance verte
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
relance verte quand vous avez une
économie qui est entièrement mondialisée
c'est des mots c'est de la com j'ai non
seulement indispensable mais c'est une
condition survie à moyen et long terme
de l'espèce humaine
le premier grand sujet c'est de réduire
l'usagé du pétrole et du gaz comme aux
gestes quotidiens
oui il faudrait faire quelque chose mais
on ne s'en donne absolument pas les
moyens et on n'a pas du tout envie même
bill gates de dire son dernier bouquin
aucune travail turn est possible si on
réduit pas notre consommation d'énergie
monsieur le maire nous explique qu'on va
rembourser toutes leurs bêtises avec une
croissance exceptionnellement forte je
voudrais qu'on m'explique comment on va
arriver à baisser la consommation
d'énergie et faire 6% de croissance de
l'autre côté ça va être compliqué
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême